eight hours straight and i'm thinking
there must be some kind of a gin inside
you to have the power to do that
and i remember my mother going off to
see
witcher doctors he would lock her up in
a room and bear up and she had the
audacity to come to me and say to me
shake my hand and i said with respect i
don't know why why won't you shake my
head
don't get my main point let me tell you
if you think that because but
recently he had ayan the liar
islamist materials of dawa these people
sadly have turned towards hate
and people like jordan peterson and joe
rogan
they don't realize that their actions by
inviting a liar like that to their
podcast
wow that seems very dangerous to me
and kovit made it possible so one more
thing before uh before we conclude
so i'm just teaching my children how to
knit i learned to knit when i was six
years old so in
round out and off this
they can disagree on some things right
but they can still love each other for
the sake of allah
welcome to the show welcome
now before we hit the we didn't get we
had we were already started but then we
were going to do the paper rock scissor
but then we decided to let uh
quebec romani go first to go ahead and
tell us a little about yourself
uh we met actually 14 years ago and we
did a program your story
and it was actually actually out of
almugadev class and then you were
telling us uh
since then you studied psychology your
principal in university
in malaysia and what else did we miss
what else did we miss
it i'm working islamic school as a
principal in malaysia and just been
working as an educational consultant
and counselor and uh
ali that was a bounty hunter he's out i
heard you you're still looking for
what's his name that guy
from the edl no i found him already you
got him
did you guys exchange some fists or what
nah you know
the thing is he was using that as a
divert tactic um
sometimes with certain individuals they
he was telling me let's have a boxing
match etc charity
i said to him we can do that after but
let's let's deal with the crux of the
matter because i know to him it's a
diversion tactic
you know it's easy to throw punches but
let's deal with your argument because
you know and he was like and he was very
hesitant
and even when i confronted him and i
found him after trying to track him down
for about eight months
a year uh many times i missed him you
know i i had information gonna be
landing in a certain airport
he was back from abroad but then it was
another airport we missed him
um but when i finally found him he had a
court case um
when i went there even when i confronted
him and just you know just showed this
ignorance then absolutely how ignorant
he is and it's just a hate preacher
and even then we're supposed to have
some kind of an agreement but like i
said these people they don't really care
yeah
they have no honor so to them it's just
about making money he's got he owns a
million pound house with a jacuzzi
you know these kind of people all they
do is just spread their hate and let
their foot soldiers
um carry out the attacks you know and
the same with the extreme side of um
you know uh isis and these guys who we
we have
you know people who follow them yeah
well they don't exist anymore
but it's the same thing then i believe
they're just you know as bad as each
other and
one carries out an attack then the other
one says look they're attacking us
the other one carries the attack and
it's just back and forth and people like
us
layman non-muslim and muslims like us
who are walking down the road we're the
ones that
end up um getting attacked so yeah
so we had another a few things to come
you're both reverts uh
converts however you want to call it i
don't know i didn't i didn't
i didn't know brother gabriel mashallah
see you i got my two brothers
on the dean's show and we're finding
these beautiful commonalities
so we got it all flipped up so beautiful
so you guys have dedicated your life to
clearing the misconceptions about islam
which means submission to the creator
not the creation you know
same way of life of jesus moses abraham
that beautiful way of life that you guys
are out there there's so many
misconceptions but yet it's the fastest
growing
growing way of life in the world you
guys dedicate your life to education
helping clear those misconceptions
and that's one beautiful thing that you
guys got in common i want to start off
with this
unless i missed something out that you
guys want to add but i want to start off
with this
uh something tell us uh uh ali we'll
start off
here there's a post a statement that you
said and it's very interesting i mean we
can kick it off from here it's going to
make for
for interesting i'm going to jump i'm
going to jump uh we're going to be
covering a lot of different topics uh
we'll also get to the thing that many
people are you know are anticipating
there's some knitting uh
controversy and whatnot but we could
touch upon that as we go along but one
you said western logic one
uh man on men action is fine pornography
is fine
one night stand fine multiple sexual
partners
fine uh marrying a piano
it's fine hold on where'd you get the
piano marigold panda was fine you know
uh
zina sex with an animal fine uh
yeah but uh pledges marriage no
how can you do that oh my god and then
you uh when i can you comment on this is
this was
this is of your statement what would you
what do you mean by this well the thing
is i show the hypocrisy
um and you know what's actually very
disturbing is that what i posted there i
i did say the western logic but if you
think about it a lot of muslims today
would a lot of muslims today would be
they would agree with that to an extent
you know when it comes to the issue of
polygamy
polygamous marriages they lose their
mind oh you can't
it's um but what about the same muslims
he would be like oh yeah i support your
right to you know
um go and marry another man this this um
sugar coated and and i i get really
irritated with this here i don't
i like we should be proud with our
religion
whatever it is while i do not like this
actions of like weakness
however there are sometimes hikmah
wisdom calls for
us to be a certain this doesn't mean
we're lying
but for example if you know you're going
to be persecuted in a variety of ways it
doesn't need to be physical
yes there might be certain things where
you're just going to have to
you know sugar coat sometimes they're
not that we want to
but we're going to get persecuted
otherwise but in certain instances we
have to academically challenge these
ideas
and sadly today muslims if you mention
the issue of
polygamy i'll be honest with you there
are people who are religious
they're religious and they would go
against this and you're like brother
are you not a muslim you're a believer
and to you
the concept of it really bothers you so
the thing is it just shows the hypocrisy
where
all kinds of stuff if you think about it
it's become normalized we're okay with
it
um you know uh homosexual acts now we're
not saying we want any kind of hate
towards these individuals
what we're seeing is that our religion
says that that is a sin
it's a major sin allah has destroyed
nations it's as simple as that
i'm not going to come and say no allah
didn't it was because no no allah
destroyed nations because of that sin
it's as simple as that
and we have to be uh be very open about
that
and especially if you're going to come
and have a go at me for a
polygamy in islam where i believe the
whole
polygamous thing allah has enabled is to
protect the rights of a woman
because men be muslim are non-muslims
it's not exclusive to being a muslim
non-muslim men practice polygamy they
just do it the wrong way they have
girlfriends side chicks and mistresses
which they use and abuse islam has come
to regulate that
to say no you can't go and hide it
number one because when these
things happens when a man wants to have
an
affair he goes and he hides it it's a
secret he doesn't honor the woman
there's no there's no approaching the
father it's all done in secret it's an
abuse
islam has come to regulate and say hold
on a second if you want to do this you
do it the right way
you approach the father you announce the
marriage you give the maha
you give her right so we we
why are we acting like we're in the back
foot when we should be proud of this and
be like look this is a part of our
religion
we should be questioning you about your
ideologies that you have
so that's the reason why i post it in a
nutshell did you got it
did you get what kind of feedback did
you get after that well to be honest
it's twitter it's it's facebook you have
all kinds of people twitter
it's it's a bit okay i didn't get any
kind of i'll be honest i thought i
thought to myself i'll put it up
you'll get taken down in about daytime
but it didn't i was quite surprised
actually
i put it on instagram as well and i got
quite good feedback actually
yeah what go ahead uh get gabrielle
do you want to comment i think yeah i
think people smell like
people might think that mirroring your
piano is like you just threw out in
there as a joke but
actually i just looked at a um an
article where there's this group of
women who are marrying buildings like
one of them is married to like the
eiffel tower
and so on so sometimes people think
we're just throwing these things there
as like we're trying to
catch a laugh but yeah this is for real
uh well look
i'm not sure uh if you're on the
manhattan or not
belizean or not but yeah it's it's uh
it's it's a challenge for those who are
practicing who are on the mental
uh of this issue and also i think
people are not i think it's being more
and more
regulated i mean sorry more and more
accepted but as you said i think it's
just done
illegally inside of allah so poliamori
is the new term that they came up with
right
polyamory is a new term that's recently
been pushed forward and it's mostly like
two women with one man or
two men with one woman and so on just
this cohabitation
it's been pushed by netflix by me you
and her whatever this
series that came up and of course they
try to naturalize into
to make these things acceptable when it
comes to and i think the issue is not
religion itself
and the issue is the injunctions
and rules that come from allah they
regulate
the social affairs of people so
collision is one if you're going to go
for ribba
it's going to be another one it's going
to go for other things
people are going to have a problem not
because of the actual
thing itself because as you said people
are practicing polygamy polygyny
polyandry
you name it it's like people having
illegal
relations in the sight of allah so the
problem is they don't mind
to for you to do whatever that you want
as long as it's not
something in line with a divine
you know uh revelation which comes from
allah and i think that's where
most people have an issue if you want to
go take two women today
and three and four there's plenty of men
who do that and they have
all kinds of contracts and they actually
even call it marriage a lot of them
actually
call it marriage whether it's in the
court
within the country or community they
deliver or not that's a different story
but they do
refer to as marriage only when it comes
to islam
that's when people start having a
problem why
well because islam is a way of life that
starts rectifying a lot of the ills of
society
and you know if islam comes in to be
okay we accept this we accept that
slowly slowly
people are going to realize that
wait a second well islam is the solution
to our problems i think that's where
this guy that you've been talking about
right and these kind of people they're
trying to always make sure that they
divert
people from seeing what islamic as well
because they're scared
that they might be like oh man oh my god
islam actually
makes sense and has the solutions to our
problems
what do you guys think he's kind of laid
low with talking about islam
but just recently because in the past we
kind of called it out
and i don't know if it was because of
that many people calling it out
our friend joe rogan but recently
he actually it seems like he started up
against i want to get you guys comments
on that he had a guest on
and we we've been kind of protesting
like hey joe we're out here why don't
you have a
a muslim on at one point he had for raza
be on here and they had a great
discussion towards the end
but recently he had ayan the liar
and i think she changed her name and
there's a great documentary it's called
ayan hursey ali exposed where they
actually these are these are
non-muslims i believe in the netherlands
who actually did a documentary and they
went to verify the statements that she
was
she was saying and they exposed her for
being a liar
so he's bringing a liar on her on his
show and he's talking they're talking
about islam
you guys know about this and what are
your comments
well you know ayann curtis has been
known for a long time she's been around
since a long time bottom line bro you
want to make money
you just leave islam and start writing a
book and start talking
smack about islam you get tons of people
supporting you
and it's been happening it's been
happening with so many people
of course they have the the leader to
say well i was a muslim
i mean i am from their culture i've gone
through this it's always the dancing
distress type of you know
you know arguments and people are
willing to put their money on that they
love that type of trauma you know
not without my child uh princesses of
saudi arabia all these you go through
airports and you see these books and
these you know
these bookshops right there on the first
uh first display right
with like these nikabi women running
away from their oppressive husbands
leaving islam blah blah blah i mean
look man this is nothing new the
the enemies of islam have been using
these kind of tactics for the longest
time
sadly obviously these people give
platforms to
these because it brings a lot of
ignorant people the majority of the
world i would say
till today still and that's why we're
doing what we're doing we're trying to
bring
the real issues to the tables because
majority of the world is still
ignorant of islam they're still
following only media
islam drive by islam drive through islam
that's all they get from the news here
and there
and it's very easy with labels
extremists
misogynist to just dismiss anyone
right so the world is upset with
religion this is the truth
and they will project those those
feelings on to islam the christian war
for example
a lot of the western countries now i
mean especially in europe they don't
identify as
believers anymore right they've had it
with religion with the church
with priests with all these things but
when they hear about islam
problem is they oversimplify things they
well it's the same thing with islam
it's just another religion organize
religion we don't need this we want to
free ourselves from the shackles
of islam so that's why it makes our work
very difficult to reach
these people because they already have
these preconceived ideas
and they dismiss you without even
listening to you
right you're not important so it's just
sad that's what we're doing what we're
doing that we're trying to reach out to
ali this isn't uh gabriel this is what
disturbs me is that you have someone
like joe
they've also banned hit jobs on the
beach
too right haven't they done that and
just to keep it fair and balanced to
bring on
an academic someone a muslim to talk but
imagine because you guys uh obviously
you've heard of joe rogan one of the top
podcasts out in the world we'll be
breaking into people's homes
mosques associations whatever looking
for
islamist materials of dawa that
means the proselytizing and
and they will try and put a stop to that
they'll try and police
literally what goes into people's minds
and comes out of their mouths
wow that seems very dangerous to me
and kovit made it possible but
he's into martial arts so imagine you're
have a person
you're bringing on who's built their
whole career on martial arts right
but this person is a fake a fake black
belt for example so now this
this woman the i i i in her uh the liar
ali i think she even changed her name is
even they exposed her name was
she changed it was um lie
but the thing is here he's bringing on
someone whose whole career is based
on a lie yeah do you find that odd
well the thing is you see sometimes
people are closet islamophobes
so when you're islamophobe you know when
you come out it's gonna you're gonna get
a bit of a backlash so you're like you
know what i'll do is
um i'll be i'll be honest i'll be very
strong um
jordan peterson as well i have the great
privilege today
of talking with ayan jerzy ali
um she's one of my heroes
i guess that's the case ever since i
read her book recently how many dropped
on a video by and
uh joe rogan um jordan peterson he does
like we'll be honest we'll be giving him
the benefit of doubt but he's starting
to sound like a closer islamophobe i'm
so sorry and then
people that follow the more radical
version of the religion that wants to
convert people to
discuss it to acknowledge it and to
automatically classify any discussion of
it
as islamophobic and that i've seen this
labeled this this label put on you
that you are islamophobic he's made
certain statements about islam which he
has no knowledge about
and then joe rogan invites this woman
the assertion that islam is a religion
of peace if they want to believe that
islam is a religion of peace let's let's
say it's a long let's come
let's do it along with him it's as if
he's saying you know what
why don't you say the things i can't let
me invite you that's what it is
i can't say it but i'm you're my guest
you know no one can say nothing you know
i invited
a guest you know i didn't tell her to
say that you know come on let's not
let's not fall around here it's very
simple what you're doing
you can invite anyone muhammad hijab
hamzazzo says there's so many people
that you can invite that could come and
talk about islam but that's not going to
be good for you you don't like
that so the thing is to invite people
like her who's an outright and she's
alive she's alive she lied about her
whole
life whole story you know and she's
there coming and she's lying and saying
you know that she's talking about forced
uh that in islam that
we're allowed to you know she's talking
about dawa and you know we can force
people to accept
they have to accept islam by the sword
this is the biggest myth ever you know
there's specific verses in the quran in
surah
2 5 6 you know very clearly islam islam
you cannot force anyone to
their your religion it's simple the
expansion of the
islamic empire does not mean there was
forced conversions
yeah it's the the empire expanding
doesn't mean you know people being
forced to accept islam
you know so people have this thinking
that oh yeah islamic empire expanded and
they're
converting people by the swords it's not
like that it's as simple as that to you
your religion to me mine
i'm i can convey but i can't force and
we have many examples we have many
examples in history where
individuals could have forced like he
had a slave where he
um he he he said look if only you
accepted islam
you know et cetera so you have many
examples where people were given the
chance to accept islam
but yeah there's an outright liar and
yeah and
she touched upon it gabriel i don't know
if you want to touch punish ali she
in her talk with joe rogan she touched
upon
and we cover this all the i mean we've
covered this so many times
but she mentioned i believe the
forced marriage honor killings
you as a as a young woman
were going to be forced into an arranged
marriage
and this is what made you flee and
and head to europe and wind up in
holland correct
that's correct had he been with us
earlier
he might have taken this initiative to
force me into marriage at the age of 15
16 17.
you guys uh you get kind of like this is
like an old record
old old record you know that just keeps
playing and you get you know tired of
hearing this
these uh it goes from someone being
ignorant who just certainly sincerely
doesn't know but then somebody who
obviously
knows the truth and then even her uh
community there called her out on that
you know
so what do you say for the for the
person who sincerely maybe just uh
bid on this and how would you respond
for this honor killing forced marriages
right right i think i think sincerity is
is the key here
and you can defer and you can have you
know issues whatever
whatever it is you know even with jordan
peterson you know
i was reading his book he's a smart guy
man you know
but he's really disappointing because he
should know better
on the academic approach of verifying
information he's an academician right so
he's being academically dishonest
in the statements that he's making you
talk about jordan peterson now this
jordan peterson yeah
yeah i'm talking about jordan peace just
wanted to make that point right because
he's very smart guys a very smart man
here you understand
it's not enough to just be smart you
have to be also honest
okay and you have to if you're doing so
much research you know how
how much academic integrity is important
and checking
verify information that is the whole you
know foundation of islam
hadith the science of verifying hadith
and knowledge and information is
based on reliability on
you know academic uh checking of who
says what who is this person are they
qualified to actually relate this
information
it's a huge huge science that what's the
objective
to just make sure that honesty is is
there when you're passing on information
right why so that
obviously you're not going to misguide
people with the wrong things with
this woman may allah guide her
obviously the enemies of islam have been
using these type of tactics from the
time of the prophet
and subhanallah i mean i was today i was
teaching a class on
the fifa and we were mentioning the
incident of the
person who came and asked the prophet
saws about the statement in the quran
o sister right referring to mary
malaysia
this is how the you they used to refer
to humble people pious people
as for their ancestors and so on you
know we are
and so on till today bro you'll find
this argument
on the answering islam website that oh
crosstalk didn't know that you know
who's the two sisters
uh aarons or mary's or you know i mean
it's just
ridiculous so these all these uh forced
marriages for
conversions uh by the sword and so on
they keep it's been refuted it's been
academically
approached and shown and so on
and i'm not denying that there was in
the history of islam
in some cases no doubt certain rulers
and leaders who did force converse there
are some
okay there's no doubt about it it's not
that that's not the question the
question is does
islam preach that is that the
theory of islam this is what's the way
as to what some person did
in this century that century i mean that
you can point to every single
nation and religion there's always gonna
be certain bad apples that interpreted
things and did things their whole way
now you have the for example you know
the
uh where the word assassin comes from
right
and how and was directed his
attacks towards them actually you know
but these were claiming to be muslims
who
right were doing all kinds of evil
things people will do a lot of things
okay
bottom line is what does islam
preach what does quran preach what does
the sun not preach
this is what we ask the world to look at
all right
this is what we asked the world to look
at
ali yeah no there's nothing i can really
add on there but it's just like you know
they just have to repeat the same cycle
you know we have a lot of people who we
deal with like
muhammad hijab who he debated a guy
called rotten wood
and he just you know he just destroyed
them you know and the thing is with
these people
you need to understand they're they're
they're like iblis
disobeyed allah and after the submarine
allah he was doomed to hell fire
now when he was doomed to hellfire he
asked even though how rebellious he was
and how it shows
it shows how rebellious he believes is
in this instance and it shows how
merciful allah is
he asks allah he makes it allah to allow
him to the day of judgment
to show like and and it's very bizarre
actually at least wants to prove allah
he said allah
give me time so i can prove you wrong um
by showing that these people the adam
that you wanted me to bow down to
that these people are not going to obey
you and it's very strange you know when
you
when you when you go for that you know
mentality so what it just shows you is
that
if bliss is end going to the hellfire
and his main objective is to take as
many people there with him
yeah as many people there with him it's
as simple as that and these people adopt
the same method as a police
you know christianity in the west is
diminishing
and literally by the millions by the
millions people are waking up like the
trinity doesn't make sense there was a
christian unitarian um in in history i
can't remember his name
he said how much longer is the
muhammadins going to laugh at us with
this concept of the trinity
they're mocking us and we need to get
rid of it he understood the problem
but the christians what's happening is
that because they've seen a lot of
people
in the west uh leaving um christianity
what people like this rotten wood guy
and his likes what they do is
if you realize even when we go to
speaker's corner the christian
missionaries there are not talking about
the bible anymore
they have left it's like when we go
there all they're doing is there's a
specific woman there
who screams for eight hours straight
when i speak his corner
insulting the prophet eight hours
straight and i'm thinking
there must be some kind of a gin inside
you to have the power to do that and
i remember my mother going off to see
which
doctors so she's continuously doing that
and then we go to other missionaries
all they're doing is talking about islam
they study this verse
and i'm thinking why do you not talk
about the good news the jew you know the
the gospel jesus loves everybody they
have totally abundant
their mission their objective is to
cause people to leave islam that's their
main objective
it's as good as saying we're going to
the fire we want to take as many people
as we can
and this shows you the intellectual
power of islam
that intellectually we have shown people
the the concept of the trinity doesn't
make sense
the bible is not reliable mark matthew
luke john and paul we don't know who
they are you know like you said we have
signs of hadith
we know a lot about a lot of companions
mark matthew duke and drug if
if you took the bible and these people
through the science of hadith
you won't even have fabricated hadith to
be worse than that so the thing is
what's happening now is these people
sadly have turned towards hate
and people like jordan peterson and joel
rogan
they don't realize that their actions by
inviting a liar like that to their
podcast
is going to cause many more people who
are going to carry out attacks that
happen in new zealand
because people get scared this is what
islam is what a violent religion we need
to put a stop to this
this is the reason why i confronted
britain first
tommy robinson jada franzen i went after
them one by one because
i knew the actions are causing people to
die just as
much when i went after the al-muhajiroun
and some of them i went after them
and to tell them to you know what you
guys at the point is madness
because it's the same thing with them
they go and preach innocent
silly people who want to belong and join
them carrier attacks in london bridge
we get the results of that we get the
backlash so the thing is this is what
they're doing and their main objective
is that you know
this is interesting because in their
discussion she talks about
the meccan period and medinan period
when she's talking to joe rogan
okay i'm sorry the fir the peaceful
muhammad is
not medina it is the peaceful muhammad
is mecca
so mecca is where he first came out and
so if he says
if if a muslim today says unto you your
religion unto me mine
i'm tolerant all of that you're invoking
mecca
and it's interesting uh i think gabriel
you quoted an eye i don't know if
this this is the one that um and then
you have the whole
you know persecution you know you guys
many people don't know that that
the muslims were and still are the most
persecuted people you know on the planet
and you had at that time
they were persecuted tortured and then
when prophet muhammad when he had
peace be upon him the opportunity when
they conquered when they came back to
mecca where they were expelled i mean
people don't i don't know if joe rogan
knows this
the scenario if he can paint it imagine
like what they watch all these
uh people out there who come back after
they've been oppressed and they just
butcher everybody and people are like
rooting them on because there was an
injustice
that had been done to them but all this
you could just name all the
from the boycotting the torture et
cetera et cetera a list just goes
miles long of all the impression and
torture and everything that happened to
the muslims when prophet muhammad
came back and conquered mecca with an
army of ten thousand strong
i mean what happened from there you guys
uh fill in the blank i mean what did he
he
what would what would a normal commander
general you know do
to to the people but what actually
happened and then he came back to mecca
right right i mean yeah we have to also
understand
did he did did he did he like slaughter
uh 90
of the people what did he do what were
the famous words what were the famous
words brothers what was the famous words
when he came back into mecca
after all these years for joe rogan so
if he doesn't know this
no he said basically i tell you what uh
yusuf ali's
prophet joseph said to his family his
brothers go for you are
free you know so he freed the people is
it
is it true he says spread the uh food
spread the peace
um this came this was when he entered
medina
when he came to medina uh he said spread
peace and spread saddams and you know
so definitely i mean the the mr process
is a balanced
message yes there were six people where
they were blacklisted when he entered
mecca they're supposed to be executed
because they're criminals
maybe sometimes again the muslims take a
very
we don't want to appear weak either okay
we're not like just pacifists right
no one should should misunderstand and
take it for granted that no the muslims
have a very strong
uh background very strong history of
warriors and
you know because we sometimes appear you
know too pacifistic
but i think what ali is talking about
here is talking about crazy people just
taking things their own manners in their
own hands and just
doing targeting innocent people and
whatnot right because they don't
understand properly the process of them
was the most balanced person the most
balanced general the most
merciful yet at the same time when he
had to put his foot down he knew how to
put his foot down
and the laws of islam are no joke you
know no doubt about it
but we need to understand context we
need to understand application
we need to understand how and what um
it's so strange and so hypocritical that
the world
recognizes the contribution of alexander
the great
or napoleon or any of the great generals
the roman generals you name them or
caesar and so on it studied in
universities as civilization
yet when he talked about prophet
muhammed saw them people are the biggest
liars and the
biggest let me use the word bigots okay
because they love to use these words
and the biggest you know academically
dishonest people
uh look at the his life he is number one
i mean there's
no doubt about it uh and not just
because
you know you know he was he was ranked
as number one and the most influential
but when you look at the discussion to
why
it's because he was so comprehensive in
his application
of law of of of virtues of morality
of bravery of a manhood of mercy
right he basically the process of
knowing knew exactly which skill to use
in which situation
and i think this is where most people
don't know today you know they want to
do this at this time and i want to do
something
else at the wrong time and this is not
wisdom hickman is to put the right thing
in the right place
at the right time at the same time we're
not apologetic we're not you know
dumbing down islam we're not to use
ali's words you know sugar-coating
things um you know we're academically
presenting islam to the world
we're saying islam is a solution islam
has a solution for criminals islam has a
solution for
a lawfulness islam has a solution
for all the ills of society that
human um you know uh society right now
is is sinking
so deep into right i mean
the world is being led by so many
different systems and philosophies that
have nothing to do with islam
yet they have not solved the problems of
of
poverty they have not solved the
problems of you know
crime they have not solved the problems
that economics and
people are dying all over the world
starving no one cares right all they
represent reporting is
all kinds of other things there are huge
problems people are depression
people are not doing well okay resources
are being consumed by a very small
percentage okay look it up look at the
research
look at you want to look at world health
organization look at other stuff not
only what they see on the news
look at everything okay and then i'm
asking okay where's the solution
you guys are leading the world with
democracy and all your western
philosophy okay
fine i mean people are saying don't talk
about this yeah but why not
why not if you look at even within their
political systems
and with them within their problems
there's huge
differences left the right all the
political parties within
there's always been a push and shot okay
so
why not everyone has the the right to to
speak and to at least ask well where is
where are the solutions
where are the solutions ali before i ask
you this next question just uh
for the audience i mean they that
documentary for
the woman that joe rogan brought on i
and the liar uh
the kind of the few things just for
people to know is
she had in fact been living and this is
what one of the lies that she was called
out for was
she had in fact been living in kenya for
over 10 years
and has never been experienced a war in
her entire life
okay so this is one of them two was to
the contrary her brother aunt and former
husband all testified that she was
indeed present at her wedding which she
she lied that she wasn't uh another
third
in fact she talks about
not having established you know because
this is what her books everything's
written on but in fact
she had maintained close contact with
her family after asylum and also
later even met with her former husband
who she was
saying she was petrified scared of
running from
uh and the list goes on of lies but how
do you
because uh ali you probably um obviously
have a lot of experience but when you
hear when you quote this
verse from the verbatim word of god
almighty allah the quran living miracle
for everybody joe rogan jordan peter
just read the book
and it's just it's it's it's amazing
like people can it's like someone who's
good at calculus and
all these sciences but then they can't
add up one plus one
it's two you'd be like what's wrong with
these people you know what i mean so
same thing with jordan peters good you
brought him up
but another person and then you made a
great example these are like closet
islam haters you know hey and they bring
out people and let them speak for
themselves being bold
you know instead of doing it for
themselves but there's this aya verse in
the quran
chapter 60 verse 8 where it says god
almighty allah does not forbid you from
being kind and just towards those who do
not fight you because of your
your deen your religion or expel you
from your homes
allah loves those who do justice when
you share this what kind of response do
you get
ali i think is uh these people that we
we confront that we
like you know the britain first be it
lauren lauren southern actually she
she did a u-turn she left the whole
thing you know and when me and muhammad
went to the free uh the freedom of
speech talk for
tommy robinson it was quite bizarre to
me i see it as a social experiment
when i went there because we went there
it was a freedom of speech for everybody
i thought okay if it's a freedom of
speech for everyone
i'm sure they won't mind me as a muslim
are coming and when we went there
if he let me speak it would have he
would have he would have made a good
point for his
uh agenda he didn't because we were
surrounded by thugs and he was about to
be killed
so this shows you this freedom of speech
is absolute nonsense
and he didn't let me speak i went there
i said look i want to you know what they
said to him
if he goes we'll kill him if he goes on
stage we'll kill him and i was like well
okay what happened to freedom of speech
there
so you can see the absolute hypocrites
um so coming back to the
question whenever i approach them when
we talk about uh
uh montana verse uh eight you know allah
does not forbid you from being just
just unkind to those who did not fight
you based on your faith or kick you out
of your houses
allah only forbids you based on
basically those who are fighting you
oh they say this is abrogated okay where
is it obligated where
where is it obligated the thing is they
have a thinking process
and they know they're doing it for other
than the truth it's not the truth
they're doing it for gains it's mainly
financial
so anything that you bring that's going
to dismantle that is a direct threat to
their purpose
so what they do is they go deny you they
don't know they shall
uh they do all kinds of stuff to get out
of it
so it's very clear the quran is very
clear that's why when i went to tommy
robinson
i asked him a very direct question can
you please show me a single verse in the
quran
the islamic literature in history that
tells us that we can go out and kill
innocent people
because they're disbelievers they're us
just because they are disbelievers we
can kill them
nothing zilch the guy i asked him 20
times in that one and a half hour and
that was my main purpose of
going to him because he had nothing he
knows that
islam does not teach this but if he
acknowledges that and he knows that this
is what
this this belief is that you hide the
truth
and it does exactly what they do they
know it's a lie they know it's a lie
they know the truth is about they cover
it
and that is the reason why the
punishment is so severe the hell fight
in the hereafter because you know it's
the truth
you know you're lying you know your
actions and your words that you're
saying are going to cause
a ripple effect like new zealand um
attacks happen in christ church but you
would rather do that because you're
benefiting
and recently one of his um friends in
tom robin vincent
they came out that they were having
cocaine parties with these money that
were raising funds for
they were having cocaine parties you
know and these men
let me just tell you one thing as well
tommy robinson and there's one guy this
is a fact
wait who was having coke they were drunk
that's that white powder you put in your
nose huh
who was who was doing who was doing that
that's verified
he's got a friend called dana white i
think it's called danny white yeah
dana wait wait dana white from the ufc
of the number one islam haters you're
talking about in the world right now
yeah one of his right hand
right hand men you can say um is that he
was having an affair with another woman
and they were saying basically they were
having cocaine parties and one of
uh the the people that were working with
tommy robinson his name was
um kainen robertson i had an interview
with him he he stopped working with
tommy robinson after
me and hijab got attacked because he
said look that day i realized that this
is this is hypocrisy tommy robin is not
about freedom of speech
he just doesn't like islam i had an
interview with him he was telling me
this he goes look there's the money that
they were raising
they were having like cocaine party
cocaine parties
and all this kind of stuff with the
money where's tommy robinson getting all
these funds from
i don't understand this guy owns a
million pound house where was again
recently just uh filed bankruptcy yeah
because there's a law a lawsuit um uh
because he um slandered
uh this um syrian refugee uh so the
thing is
most of these people they're absolutely
hypocrites they come tommy robinson
uh even this this friend that danny dano
what is called
um jada franzen paul golding avi yemeni
these people you know they would always
come to me and talk about um a woman
being abused in islam
do you know avi yemini in australia
there's he's a like a proper zionist
yeah he threw a um you know cutting
chopping board
yeah he threw that at his wife tommy
robinson once was caught
on the in the public by an undercover
officer abusing his wife
paul golding paul golden you know paul
golden britain first paul gorden and
jada franzen that woman with the red
hair
do you know there was a documentary paul
golding is that is that is that one of
the
women that was trying to uh uh shake
your hand
and then is that the one yes yes you
know that one she
keeps talking about woman's right here
you know paul golding that guy
he she was with he would lock her up in
a room
and beat her up did you know that
you know no he would lock her up in a
room and bear up and she had the
audacity to come to me and say to me
shake my hand and i said with respect i
don't know why why don't you show me
our main point let me tell you if you
think that because we're christians and
i'm holding this cross
that you can come here you can lie in
our faces
and that you can attack our people
but her boyfriend was putting his hands
on her in a illegal way but she was too
busy
she was making a big deal because i
didn't shake her hand in a way of
respect i didn't want to touch her
and she had a big fuss about it but
behind closed doors
her her boyfriend paul gordon was
beating her up physically putting her
hands on her and literally beating her
up and locking her
uh in rooms this is the hypocrisy all of
them are wife peters wow okay
well before we go before we go on and
move on we spent a lot on this so
just because we know that islam is the
the same way of life that jesus lived
moses lived
the last fight of mr prophet muhammad
that call for the human being
to acknowledge that there's one and only
one creator of the heavens and the earth
and he sent messenger and that simple
message is to worship the creator the
one and only
and to be morally upright is a simple
message so if jordan peterson
if joe rogan i and her
any of them if they turned their life
around and they wanted to you know
uh rectify their affairs and you know
they had a
you know they had a moment that they
realized that okay what's the true
purpose of life you know and they look
at the evidence if they just look at the
evidence the
preservation of the quran if they look
at the signs that are in there the
prophecies the miracles if they look at
the life of prophet muhammad sincerely
you know from the proper lenses and they
like most people you know when they do
they accept this is the truth
you know what would you guys say to them
now like if you had a chance to sit with
them just quickly what would you say to
to these three individuals
well i would say i mean obviously they
they uh they read the quran if they just
open their eyes and their hearts
yeah i'll give them to the quran yeah i
mean that's the best thing for them you
know and then
subhanallah once they uh embrace islam
and muslims are gone they're brothers
and sisters what translation because you
know their orientalists if they pick up
you know
there's been deliberate attempts by some
orientalists to go ahead and translate
the quran so if they get a hold of one
of these
which which clear quran
so pick up the quran read it all right
instead of talking about it read the
book i want to say read ali what would
you say to them to joe rogan
our friend joe rogan who's uh who's
actually
yeah same you know same thing you know
yeah like you know at the end they look
if you want to judge a book you know
or judge me one you know imagine imagine
you're you're learning about someone
imagine me learning about joe rogan
or jordan peterson i don't i don't watch
any of the videos i don't watch his
podcast i just go and learn about him
from someone that doesn't like him
imagine i invite him and i say you know
tell me a bit about joe rogan oh joe
rogan's a woman abuser oh where is her
what what an evil guy
you know and then how is that would that
be fair how would joe rogan feel and
enjoy the jordan pizza they will feel
like they'll be so angry they're like
ali you could have come to me and speak
to me
and you're here inviting people that
dislike me and you're learning
you're getting to know me via someone
that doesn't like me how is that fair
but i'm asking you the same question
jordan peterson and joe rogan how is
that fair that you're getting to know
the quran
why are people that don't like it and
then you are and you're
and you have these emotional feelings
and be like oh this is this can't be
from god
well how can i blame you in the context
well i can't blame you
because you're getting to know a
scripture not for yourself but via the
enemies
you wouldn't like it for yourself so
don't do it to us beautiful
beautiful good advice from both of you
guys uh gabrielle tell us uh
you you recently also posted a statistic
a 2017
study can you go ahead and elaborate on
this and in in the statistic it talks
about really just
really odd it's the 24 percent
non-denominational we
often hear this with uh christians you
know but
what's this study talking about well
people are as i said they're moving away
from
faith you know they're realizing
we're living in the 21st century
information is more available
people are realizing that their religion
is not the correct one i think the
the build-up of human beings it's built
in us is
hardwired in us that we we believe in
the higher being or we have
the ability the feelings right that's
why a lot of people turn towards
buddhism or all kinds of different
eastern religions for that spirituality
right so people have left you know
catholicism
orthodoxy and so on and so forth they
want to have
freedom a lot of people are looking for
just no commitment they just want to
have the spiritual experience but they
don't want to commit they keep saying
like i don't want to organize religion
i don't want laws i don't want this i
don't want that
islam is not that islam is a way of life
that covers every single aspect of your
life
and subhanallah i mean this is all like
i don't want laws i don't want
organizing i organize religion is this a
big misconception because as soon as you
open your door and step out of your
house you're gonna have you know
you're gonna have to drive in a certain
you know part of the road you're gonna
have to
obey speed law you're gonna have to now
you're gonna have to wear a master you
know
and line up behind the special lines
right so
everyone has to follow or they'll follow
anyway but when it comes to
religion or to to god they have a
problem with with rules and regulations
fine you know i know that they have
problems with
regulation made by human beings that
have caused a lot of
a lot of problems in the world a lot of
injustice but we're asking you to follow
the perfect law from the almighty that
has
no flaws and no problems that's going to
solve your life problems actually
so yeah people are moving away man
they're moving away they're saying
they're non-nominational they're saying
they're atheists they're saying they
don't believe in god
the world is in darkness when it comes
to spirituality right now to the truth
anyway you know
and i believe that people are cutting
themselves short
by pushing islam on the side and just
putting it with
everyone else you know islam is just
like every other religion
i don't need it honestly i do always
advise people read the quran
visit a mosque mashallah we live in a
world right now there's a mosque almost
in every city
just you owe it to yourself
just at least that when you're on your
death bed
you're not going to regret and there's
no guarantee that you won't
they're going to say hey at least i went
and talked to some muslims at least i
i read i'm reading all kinds of you know
garbage magazines and paparazzi and all
that
you know following all kinds of social
media entertainment let me at least
give the quote um a read
okay a thought a little bit read maybe
another book like the first and final
commandment for example by dr lawrence
brown you know which is a very very
intellectual book that i think would
appeal to everyone
all right something like that it's a
good read you know just just
the worst that's going to happen is
you're going to get a bit more
you know a bit more information about
islam like that's not
new i mean there is nothing negative
about that but
every human being has this
responsibility you owe it to yourself
to at least right now where the world is
looking at islam
islam is mentioned everywhere don't you
wonder what
is islam don't you wonder like why
why is it all islam islam islam islam is
not
like just just do
do yourself a favor and just
you know this goes with my next question
we can connect this uh ali
tell us you also you sent the message to
a representative of the house over here
a politician you talk about the alphabet
movement and you said
has a right to live without fear in
america
but sister her name is uh ilhan i
believe omar
how do you live without the fear of god
allah for promoting an alphabet movement
as a muslim what will you say to god
almighty allah on the day of judgment
for the five letters regarding this
alphabet movement
we have five letters too it's haram
you know you know the thing is it's when
you go for these kind of positions we
have our mayor who's a muslim as well
you know
so the thing is you see when you come to
these
you it comes at a cost just as you get
involved in
when you start seeing the unseen or the
you know
etc you interact with the jinns they ask
you to do certain things
but it comes at a cost that you lose
your hair after
so when you get involved in these things
you need to understand you're being
surrounded
we don't see non-muslims as our enemies
only those who are
they are in our enemies yeah general
non-muslims we have no problem with them
you go by your life we go about our life
but we need to understand is that they
have a way of life
they have their sharia now when you get
involved in that
you need to understand that shaytan
shaytan's deception is real we know that
okay there's a whole book and a book
written on it
when you get involved in politics or
whatever it may be you need to
understand something yeah
that's why i don't really agree with
this for example this concept of
uh happy-go-lucky muslims like yeah
we're everyone okay oh let's
hold hands hippie because this comes at
a cost because what's gonna happen is
you're showing the goods uh like islam
as a whole is beautiful yeah
but if you just thought for example yeah
for example the process
he did this he did this person went to
war as well brother did you know he went
to war
you know he fought battles people were
killed as well so if we don't
decide and we show and when i'm in this
side this is a side where
they they had to go to war because of
certain reasons the prosecution never
went there and persecuted people for no
uh
uh um like attacked or forced people to
accept islam
we're not talking about stuff like that
what i'm saying is that when you get
involved with these things
what happens is you're gonna have a
non-muslim crowd now no this non-muslim
crowd is going to come to you and
say yeah thank you very much you're
doing a great job etc you're going to
want it like it or not you're going to
kind of
um be influenced by that psychologically
because you're going to be i don't want
to disappoint them
so for in omaha to come out and to say
something about the lgbqt
she knows she will get an uppercut
a very annoying physical apricot she
knows so
now you're in a position where you uh
that you've gained into politics
and now you have to do certain things
we've got siddhi khan here who's going
to the
hindu temples shrines yeah and showing
some kind of respect i'm i'm very sure
it was him
and i'm thinking like like your brain
stops and you're like
this this is like okay someone could
this is [ __ ] yeah you can say this is
[ __ ]
so the thing is when you get involved
with this stuff it comes across
it is very just the reason why we have
sister ilhan omar who at an lgbt event
is dancing with them
and i'm thinking like what enough is
going through your head what like
you can say look we say we do not want
harm to con
people we're not asking for anyone to
pronounce people but we are outright
saying
it is haram it is not permissible yeah
now and this comes in israel for example
mufti meng he had the
interview with the danish the danish
thing we're going to come to but even
over there well he said i agree with him
he said you are allowed to be gay in the
context in your country
and as muslims we can't say this is
wrong in your land
you being gay i can't come and say to
you no you can't
and this is what multimedia so we're
going to come to that later that is
understandable but to go and outright
promote and be like no there's nothing
we're fighting for the rights for lgbqt
to get married i genuinely am thinking
what on earth is going on
do you guys think both now when you hear
this because for someone like her and
others
that you mentioned to get in that
position you got to be educated you got
to have a
basic grounding in politics you have to
have a basic
understanding on certain topics you got
to be educated well informed
you think this is a lack of being
grounded in the dean spending enough
time
really understanding your deen yeah i
think that's the main issue right people
don't understand smell
when they say things like that because
they'll find something like
la [ __ ] dino cumulating and say look
you'll be yours to me be mine
it's a very slippery slope man when you
start compromising on your
on your uh you know your issues and um
you know there's you you might think
you're okay your house is safe
but there's spy around it right and
you're like look i'm not gonna get
involved and let the fire be around that
you
if you want to light your fire your
house on fire light it up it's up to you
right
this is your right yeah but that fire is
gonna spread man
that fire is gonna spread to your house
into every house um
sadly i don't agree with what ali said
right now you know we can discuss it
later but within the correct context
uh but it it will come to your house it
is coming here
it's coming to the muslim countries
because the muslim thing you know it
didn't start from here
it's all imported you know through the
culture through the media and so on and
people kept saying look man
whatever you have to do you do it it's
up to you no problem
then when you know the parents wake up
and they're like my son is gay
my daughter's gay what do i do now and
you're like well it's a bit late man
because you didn't do anything about it
you know
the the lgbtq community doesn't shy away
from doing that down
being very aggressive and pushing
forward
and the sister han i don't know i mean
she's
obviously as ali said right she's in
that position she's gonna have to play
their their music you know what i mean
because if not she's not gonna be there
that's why she is there that position
what you're gonna do you're gonna say oh
i don't agree with you guys of course
she's gonna be gone in no time
so this is where you sell you know and
actually as allah says
you know they for they lose their dunya
because
i mean let's say she's not really
effective in this dunya at all
and then she's compromising if she
believes that what she's doing
is correct and that is a huge issue if
she actually believes it
if she's just lying around messing about
whatever knowing that
okay that's a different story but if she
believes but she's preaching what she's
saying
that man and there's a big problem and
i'm not defeated or anything like that
but
any scholar there's no difference of
opinion and that would be a huge
problem all right so let's just leave it
at that i guess
i um we're almost out of time but i
really uh
are you are you planning on visiting uh
malaysia anytime soon ali are you
visiting uk anytime soon gabrielle
uh i'll be visiting the uk inshallah yes
hopefully but i love the
yeah i'd love for you guys inshallah to
two brothers to
come together inshallah with you guys
yeah
so what uh what what else you guys think
uh in this short amount of time you
think is important now that we
need to touch upon anything else that we
missed
no not really no okay
so now we talked about one being
grounded in a deen very important
uh we talked about we called out some of
this hypocrisy now with uh you know the
closet
uh islamophobes uh that's right who uh
let other people speak for them with the
uh
joe rogan uh jordan peterson we talked
about the mercy of god almighty allah
that people could have been on that path
you had so many of the
companions of prophet muhammad who are
fighting against islam right
but you know many of the the honorable
ones at the end
they ended up accepting islam right so
the
the doors of mercy that's uh one thing
subhanallah good look uh
the issues that ali and i are dealing
with or you're dealing with eddie and
all these challenges are again to an
extent
you know also our fault that we're not
being basically a bit more
pushy in our doubt and i'm not saying
that you have to have lack of wisdom and
so on
the problem is the other side is pushing
hard you know you can see people are
getting more and more brave
to attack the muslims to do things
against muslims to call him out
come to a podcast talk about this like
why you know and because we're kind of
sitting around and yeah something i
would do a lot of good work but
is how effective is and so on and so
forth
can be questioned right but bottom line
is
fire's spreading if we the muslims don't
wake up
and don't start you know opposing and
being even if you're in an amazing
country within the law you are
allowed to defer be it lgbtq
beer whatever it is the christians do it
the
the uh the staunch christians and the
bible belt to many they do it
we need to if if we're going to have
this these kind of corporations i think
we should
select who we do it with if we want to
protect our deen because there's a lot
of people who are not muslim
who share certain values and ethics and
morals with us
and i think we can learn a lot from and
if you look at all the major movements
within these non-muslim countries via
malcolm x
recently celebrated his uh you know his
demise
i mean look at what he stood for within
a system that was against him
look at the impact that he left why
because he went
head-on now people would say man maybe
he's this his dad he said could have
said this better or that better
yeah but look at the impact that he left
because he believed
in something indeed and he was not weak
or he was not
afraid to say what he believed and now
he died for it that's a different story
um i'm not sure you know people are
scared to talk about this like you know
shahada or dying for
you know the sake of allah isn't because
it's extremists right but you find
martyrs in so many different cultures
and so many different
right when it comes for causes be it
social causes be
the african-american movement and so on
bottom line is within
these non-muslim countries within the
law if you study the law and you
understand the system that you live in
they chose to live with
and you still choose to live it everyone
chooses you
can move within it you can counter you
can't say
and i do say and even if it's costing my
job that lgbtq is wrong
it is a disservice to our children it is
abuse to our children
it is not correct to target a child at
four years old or at zero just a month
just you know the year old we're not
going to decide is gender we're not
announcing their gender
this is abuse okay allah subhanahu wa
genes don't lie your dna doesn't lie
like come on who you're fooling
you know what i mean but the problem is
if we take that attitude of like oh
hands off i'm not going to challenge
anyone
let's just hold hands sadly the fire
will come to our houses and it is these
guys are injecting into the curriculum
the curriculum is being attacked
are you kidding me four year old has to
read a book about coming out and this
and that i have two blue dads
this is the curriculum right now it's
not fair
but because if the muslim community
doesn't
starts you know doesn't stand up and
start you know growing some you know
some some guts
uh we will be pushed we will be pushed
that it reaches our own children all
families gonna wake up your daughter
your son acting funny and doing weird
stuff
and then it's going to be late and then
the parents come to my office they start
crying please help
is there any counseling any any therapy
that they can do to reverse the
the the the you know the damage and it's
like not so easy
yeah they have the puberty blockers that
they're trying to implement they're
trying to
pass laws that now you can't even as a
parent have any say i had a uh
brenda lipsack i had a a teacher school
teacher who exposed
you know the deliberate kind of like you
know stealth attempt
to uh corrupt the minds of the the
little ones uh do you see this happening
what are your thoughts on this ali
yeah it's a it's a reality you know at
the end of the day
what we're seeing is that the
movement is not just saying except me
what they're saying now is i i i'm
basically going i i want you
to be like me that's what they're saying
they're not saying
have respect and this is so panel it
just shows you you know this is it's
it's it's a universal or sadly
you know people just think you just no i
just want you to respect me except no
you want me to be like you
you want my kids to be like you this is
an outright it's a it's like
an intellectual world that's why i
believe you have the far right and you
have the far left
yeah the far right they they physically
want to harm the muslims
they just want or anyone that describes
them they physically want to harm you
the far left want to destroy your soul
they're after your soul the far right
want your body
the farthest want be assault i would
rather the far right i prefer the far
right because the fire i want to kill me
at least
inshallah as the believer the far left
want my soul
so that means on my shahada i'm going to
be like
hold on a second actually so the thing
is here is that this is why i believe
the far left is
much much more dangerous than the far
right the pharah i know what they're
about i know what they want
they come physically i can attack
physically the far left and
even intellectually we can but they are
attacking
us in in a spirit in a spiritual way
where this is this is a greater harm to
me
than that could ever be so that's why i
agree there is an outright war
um towards all not just muslims because
the christians and the jews
you know people you know um that have
faith so the thing is it's we need to
challenge alhamdulillah we do challenge
it intellectually
um and we do short hypocrisy uh but the
thing is now it's like
the more they come into power i believe
there might be a time where they would
literally
persecute the the the muslims christians
whoever it may be they will persecute
you don't get it twisted don't think
yeah they're coming now it's no no no no
trust me some when it comes
the the time comes they would if needed
be they would force you you know they
would force you to accept their way i
believe this you know
um so yeah and then we just need the
challenges simple as that would you guys
say we have more in common with one side
where
i often say look we're more we're more
christian than the christian
if you want to say christ-like meaning
that we follow the way of jesus of
worshiping one and only one god
we greet like he did peace be with you
we don't eat the pig
we follow the commandments of god
almighty we
pray like him and we're more
conservative than the conservatives so
we have so much have you had these
conversations when one group and you're
like wow we agree on so many so many
different issues it's like if they'd
only just
you know but they've been fed they don't
believe a lot of the media
out there but when it comes to islam
they swallow it hook line and sinker do
you see this hypocrisy
yeah they'll know that there's a lot of
groups out there that i think we can
build
some bridges and work with uh as long as
we we make clear that who we are and we
don't compromise our
our fundamentals okay um and sadly
that's the problem like that we're faced
with right now that some of our
leaders and our you know they're not
working with those people they're
they're rather work with the lgbtq
now massager are getting a revamp you
know you have to get one of these people
to give you some cultural training what
not
i think california is also like there's
there's laws that are being passed where
you're gonna have to have someone in the
board or in the ministry that is
representing that community
and you're talking about the blockers
the blockers is not just the issue the
problem is that the parents don't want
to allow their children to take those
blockers
the children's aid society or their uh
children's services will take the
children away
i understand that so yes as ali said
they will be persecuting you they will
be and they are already
right so it's not a joke my call is
again and i i hope it reaches all the
guys and the preachers who have a lot of
following
start talking about real stuff start
educating the community
don't be afraid within the law within
the get some some legal advice get some
you know scholars or some brothers to be
on your board to protect you
and within that within the framework
that you're living in i understand
you know people say oh yeah it's funny
for you you're in malaysia yeah you
should see what's going on with the
lgbtq community here
and what they're pushing for they're
pushing very very hard but
people are pushing back so it's coming
it's coming to all the muslim countries
bottom line is are we educating our
communities are we training our children
are we fighting a legal battle are we
fighting back because this is not allah
there's a lot of non-muslims
who agree with us and they will support
and we can join hands with these people
sadly we find that you know people are
calling to
fight for the rights and rules and laws
of the lgbtq you know what i mean
amongst the people that we used to
respect and we used to
follow and wish to learn from and it's
oh it's confusing i just want to bring
sorry to to take i i promised uh one of
the chefs
who is a graduate from medina okay who
was my client last week
and he has a bigger beard than you uh
you know uh eddie
and me and i promise that i'll take this
message to whoever's listening
okay he said he is a homosexual okay
he is fighting a huge internal jihad and
he said to all the brothers who have big
followings
by you guys not talking about this and
you guys not
addressing this issue and by people
talking that hey you know it's okay we
can work with them we can
he said it's killing us not only him
others as well
he says we it's like we almost want to
give up
this guy's been fighting it for 15 years
he's been fighting it for 15 years he
said i feel like committing suicide i
can't take anymore
the more i see people not addressing the
issue the more i see that they're
leaning towards it or towards accepting
it it's
just invalidating all these years that i
fought walla
i'm bringing this message from this
brother okay
just so you guys understand allah
forgive me
if i you know get a bit hot sometimes
and what not but i hope
people understand this is not a joke i'm
not joking i'm not trying to build my
career someone's back
okay i'm not messing around allah knows
my knee of course i cannot
put it on the screen for you but i just
you know
yes i do allah forgive me i've been
advised but please take things seriously
please i beg you for the sake of allah
and just carrying this message from this
brother may allah forgive us
when you talk about like we started off
uh we got five more minutes
the uh the alphabet movement here we
started off with talking about the
p uh do you find it ironic i just
thought about this i always do when they
have all these letters
what what why don't they throw the p in
there
the p
we started off with uh your quote
actually your post
that talked about the p piano
[Laughter]
no the what at the end number seven
number seven oh oh oh
yeah yeah it's a blessing from allah
yeah so one more thing before uh before
we conclude
so i'm just teaching my children how to
knit i learned to knit when i was six
years old and i remember
the moves in round out
and off in round out
and off and now my kids are learning i
just got them a set of knitting needles
and some
huge wool and we said let's go for it
mashallah you know minky and zinji can
have a little blanket or two
and inshallah we can also spend our time
a little bit constructively so that's
that's round that's off so in
round out and off in
round out and off and that's the last
one in round out and off that's 20
stitches
and let's see how far we've gotten
masha'allah there goes ooh
there we're getting there mashallah see
that was kind of the knitting battle and
uh
uh gabriel ramani he had like a rap song
and this and that and that and this
is
and i want to show here how two brothers
they can disagree on some things right
but they can still love each other for
the sake of allah you follow me
so of course we don't we we we agree on
something that is more powerful than
that that's the tohi that's the pure
monotheism right and to avoid [ __ ] to
avoid that this
angers god almighty allah and you're
going to have within families you're
going to have people who
put their hands up here put their hands
up there you disagree on some
some political understanding but at the
end of the day you come together your
family
right so you two are family you can
disagree on some things but at the end
of the day you agree on something much
stronger than all that
so what was the kind of contention here
that you guys wanted to uh
uh or you wanted to clarify and maybe
some
misunderstanding or something to be
honest i wanted to
stop gabriel maybe if we can just maybe
just tell us what like
for example what he didn't express it in
the videos but like it would be nice if
he can tell us like what was
going through his mind like the
frustration that he had because the
thing is it's very important
when it comes to these matters of
muslims disagreeing with each other
you know a lot of times sometimes we
need to put ourselves into the other
person's shoes
you know there might be some
disagreements but you know like we need
to have
love towards the believers it's very
important in the uk and
we have a big problem of certain groups
maybe you wouldn't want me to mention
them you know
uh but they're very hostile towards the
believers very very hostile physically
uh in intellectually in all angles you
know we've seen
uh how they treat the believers how they
treat the muslims and with me it's not
like that you know just because i
disagreed with brother gabriel on a
certain subject
i don't automatically be like all you
know i don't like this guy and you know
and we have this attitude you know sadly
this the lifestyle that we live in you
know everything is we replace it easily
you know amazon prime i don't like
the next one um you know it's we have
this attitude and we
implement it with our friends and
muslims as well he does something to
annoy me
i've never seen any good from him he's
finished this is a wrong attitude that's
the reason why
i came to the uh the dean's show because
you know brother gabriel is a believer i
love him for the sake of allah i don't
have
any kind of animosity towards him we can
disagree we'll talk about that
and we will leave it at that but it's
not like oh i don't like gabriel now
brother gabriel doesn't like mufti
making our multi man doesn't
like him and we don't like this is no we
have to talk about these matters we're
believers we love each other we want the
best for the ummah
we're coming from different angles so um
i just wanted to
start gabriel if you can just just from
his you know
discuss there but maybe just to give
what happened you know etc because you
deal with clients etc
what happened and maybe just elaborate
and educate the muslim youth
on how to deal with disagreements um and
you know
where we're coming from
yeah so exactly i did speak with uh
multi-bank on the phone as well
and a couple of other shares have called
me and talked and so on and so forth you
know from there i think
good things came out of it and we can
see that
there's been a discussion around this
issue i think
people need to understand that there was
no
nitpicking i was not picking on niching
or
i was not thinking necessarily on
multimec as a figure i was
putting or picking on maybe what he was
representing not only in the video
there's a couple of others
that have been pointed out a few times
and it's been over the years actually
i'm just so people understand the
background i don't have anything against
him personally or anything like that
only that we talked and so on you know
we gave each other our advice
and so on i cannot disclose as to what
we talked and what not but we just you
know kind of gave each other advice
background that i was comfortable i
reviewed my video yesterday again i
know that was a bit hot and you know
mashaallah a few different shares told
me okay maybe you could have said this
in a
different tone and so on obviously these
days um
it is it is uh sensitive people get
upset and whatnot
and i agree i think my tone sometimes i
get a bit passionate
but you know also you have to understand
when you deal with you know
people from all over who are falling
into
this trap of and i'm not saying he's
putting a trap or anyone else what i'm
saying is there is a trap out there
to e-masculinize man to make him more
feminine
and so on so when that happens when you
see
the products of this not necessarily
that an activity is haram necessarily
you know this is haram that is how and
what is
kind of what that might be interpreters
as
and it's not only about knitting i don't
want to bring up the other things
because i want to start again another
issue
okay i have and others have also talked
to him and
highlighted some of his other posts so
it has nothing to do with that and
nothing to do with disrespecting
i looked through the video again again
it was my tone maybe i think i mentioned
a kid
who i'm going to refute a kid and i
think maybe people thought i'm calling
him a kid no it was another video
of a kid their child giving within one
of their lectures
so i was not calling him a kid or stuff
i would never do that and that's not my
way i've been taught by my shifts never
to disrespect
okay the people of knowledge in the guys
even if i disagree with them
okay yes i know that my tone was a bit
tough but you know i mean
it is a huge issue
i didn't call him as not being a real
man or anything like that because i know
you've
highlighted some of his achievements
masha'allah all i said is basically
if even if you're going right now to a
lot of these videos and posts
um that you know we should someone of
his stature of his
mashallah follower could be a bit more
balanced in posting a little bit more
about
maybe husband's rights about respect for
husbands right now i have a case today
this morning where the woman punched the
husband in the face during a flight in
the airplane in the
face man and there's you know it's just
i want to be the
boss i'm them you're not a man this and
that uh and you'll be like what
what does that have to do with this guy
it's not having to do it
it's a bigger picture i think people
restricted it to the knitting and to
follow
you know it's not to do with that is
that
i believe we need to bring about this
issue a bit more to talk about
the emascularization of man we need to
have more
activities they're a bit more conducive
towards building real men
and i think the chefs and the guys have
to talk a little bit more
a little bit more about this to balance
it out
the jokes with you know like you know
the woman is the law
or the you know the happy wife happy
life these kind of things right it's
good it's nice it's cute and so on i
understand that
men should treat their lives better
there's a lot of bad men out there as
well
who mistreat their women and i
appreciate you know the
people highlighting those issues and
trying to teach men to be softer towards
their wives no doubt this is the student
of the prophet
but the process you know also raised
right that he was fighting battles he
was a real man he was strong and so on
people made it about knitting it was not
about knitting it was not about picking
on someone
is it's a bigger issue it's the issue
that right now if you look and you are
to
pick amongst the people who are doing
dawah how many people are actually
raising some of these issues be it lgbtq
and how they are happy that we talked
about it today
i know ali keeps it real and a lot of
his videos i've seen
i've been following ali for a long time
you know
being on the street there on the ground
right it's not behind a desk or behind
the
notice lecturing so that i appreciate
you know what i mean is a lot of real
stuff going on i think we just need
a bit more we need to talk about a bit
more
real issues and when i talked mostly
explained to me as to
why sometimes he might not do it and
this and that
i disagree with him i advise them and
that's pretty much
it
you know one thing that sometimes i get
hate on as well is and i think
and this is what i'm trying to
understand you know the reason why i
wanted to elaborate on this topic is
because
the thing is the umma needs to
understand that
different people give different styles
of dawah yeah and
i believe your one is more like cut
throat and i believe alma needs that
it's definitely something that
we definitely need it's cut throat it's
needed and it's i'll be honest it's
something
within my style as well where i like to
be like that as well i like to be
cut throat sometimes you know i like to
get to the point
and i think it needs it as well but i
think sometimes what happens is like
i used to once your brother um and the
sheet artist
yes yeah so basically once i remember i
was at an event and
oma issa was performing and you know his
nasheed style is a bit different
yeah it's it's it's a bit different and
there was a brother and he was like oh
look at this brother
you know this soft voice feminine voice
this time i was like you're actually
backed by in him and you're in front of
me you're back by the guy
you know and i was like aki look he does
his style
it doesn't make it haram yeah you might
not like it
you might not like the style okay i
agree with you you might say you know
what it's not for me i can say some of
all my essence in this sheets
are not for me some of them i love some
of them they're not just for me it
doesn't make
him wrong it doesn't make what he's like
when i look at the bigger picture like
i've recently i got into doing a skits
yeah so for example i do certain skits
and some people come in and say to me
you know what this is is this the dawah
is this etcetera and i was thinking
look my if i'm using specific style yeah
okay
now you might think that and when i'm in
you i'm not talking about brother
gabriel or brother eddie i'm talking in
general the person
if this if it doesn't fit your style or
you don't like it or some people say
it's cringe
some people messaged me said brother you
know that was a big crit i said maya
bless i appreciate i know when i was
doing it and watching
it it was cringe for me to edit it i was
i was cringed out myself watching myself
but the objective that i was trying to
get out
if i sometimes you know we have this
thing of you know i will fight for the
sake of allah you know i would do this
for the sake of allah
well can we sometimes be cringe for the
sake of allah
sometimes it's not about ego it's not
about what people i don't care what
people think about me you get it they
can say it's cringe
if i'm doing something that's
permissible i i'm using a
style in the tower i shouldn't get
attacked for that people were attacking
me
like why are you doing this etcetera
this no i said yaki is that haram no
okay that's the preference if you don't
like it why are you discrediting what i
do
because it doesn't fall into your
preference or your style because some
brothers are
ruggle they like to stop a bit you know
cut bro
but if some other diet is not doing it
that way is it
fair is it fair to have a go at them
for not doing it the way you deem it
should be
this this is why i think it's good yeah
that's a good point um
look the thing is abby the thing is um i
never said it
so that's clear i never said that it's
impermissible
sometimes you know they had he had
weaving plates uh you know uh
and so and i said that's fine i mean you
know i think within the first
five minutes i mentioned hadith
processing uh sowing his clothes and
mending his shoes
in my video i mentioned it three times
that i checked in the first five minutes
because i knew that and and still people
that's all they read in the
or wrote in the comments they're in the
process and you know so it's close i'm
like guys listen man it's like
three times i mentioned um the thing is
with the different styles ali
is uh allah prophet
was soft and he was strong the prophet
of sin was a balance in sam cameron
so if we follow a strategy for islam and
for our dawah he is the
one and only that we should look for of
course we look at the sahaba as well
yeah you would have
he taught that to his men to his
companions
i agree that there's a softer approach
sometimes but there's a context
i agree that there's a stronger approach
sometimes and there's a context i don't
think i'm cut throat because if you look
through my videos
there's a lot of intellectual stuff i
talk about education i talk about
all kinds of times yes i do get hot
sometimes i'm a bit different
it depends not necessarily cutthroat but
i think we have to have a company
my only contention was that i understand
this style
i'm just saying can he do a bit more
being in a position of your fears
of so much influence where we have so
many problems in this world
that the community that follows him a
lot
a big large community are suffering from
these issues
and he can make a huge with a small post
a huge difference in maybe teaching men
how to be better to device okay fine
nicely but also teaching women how to be
a bit more respectful to their husbands
a bit more careful towards their
households and their children and so on
a bit maybe a bit more aware as to the
lgbt agenda what's happening with the
schools because a lot of these people
have children in schools and so on
and i brought up the issue of i just
felt that for a person of his
statute was just not appropriate
and that's why imam shafi said he said
that if i knew
that drinking cold water would tarnish
my mood i would only
drink warm water right he just has the
statement i can send you the statement
arabic
it's it's just about one of the the
requirements in the
hadith we're accepting that it's not
wrong okay it's not wrong to it's not
haram to drink
this water that is just how people might
perceive it
and is it something that someone of the
statue
i would just say that he could do a
little bit more balance i understand
that it's
different style but i think the
processing had the comprehensive style
there was uh sometimes a bit of
harshness or strength or let's say
firmness even in the squat pass to the
point that
you get red and so on when you talk
about certain things
and sometimes you find him crying and
his beard wet and subhanallah you know
just touching an orphan's head and just
dealing with the children
so beautiful when you just softens your
heart you know that's pretty much
what i was trying what i'm what i'm
trying to make but i think
work living in the 21st century the
challenges that we are facing right now
2021
with all the new laws that have been
passed by all the
new push the new curriculum uh people
just gotta lock down
i understand that okay spend time with
the children but
let us look also at other things as well
because there's a lot of issues that we
can address and people in power and that
mashallah influence can really influence
the people can really
that the indian pakistani community has
huge problems with dowry with
abuse with this um sorry ali you know in
london
i have many of my clients from london
the streets of london somalis are
stabbing each other and the pakistanis
are stabbing each other drugs
and so many problems man you guys have
so many issues in that community
and people don't understand what's
happening on the streets of london you
know uh you know i talked to parents
you know i had a sister whose son got
stabbed you know
the kids were coming to our door trying
to establish the son it's it's not a
joke before i need to understand there's
a lottery on i think
a lot of these people might might having
instagram facebook they might be
scrolling and seeing a video
of multi-language or whoever and they'll
be like oh brothers you know let's
do this brothers don't do that it's not
just about let's love each other but
also
the process says that i
i i the sahabah used to ask the person
about the good things i used to ask them
about the bad things
you know like we need to balance it out
if you make a video like guys don't do
that guys this is not correct guys
you know let's be a bit more this think
he can reach like a
huge are you are you are you saying i've
heard you talk about
like uh gabrielle like for instance if
you
if we talk about people talk about uh
the rights
you know that islam gave for the muslim
woman you know
that she is to be honored cherished
respected
uh you know and then you quote the
hadith from the last fundamental you
know the best of you are those who are
best of their wives
uh so you know to to live with them on a
footing of kindness of mercy you know
this is just clear but at the same time
are you saying to be balanced like you
also have if you're if you're
instructing the man there like many men
like hold on
but what about you know if you also
where the righteous women are devoutly
obedient and straightened
from the quran then you also should you
be balanced and quoting the hadith that
are also talking about if i would
if i would have ordered anyone to make
sajdah i would order the wife to her
husband
uh also you know just there's so many
about when the woman these things have
to be explained and educated
educated so is that is that what you're
saying like watch your attitude
because your husband is your paradise
your hellfire right so we don't hear a
lot of these but it's just like okay
keep it balanced
is that what you're saying there's a
reactionary movement right now obviously
because
no doubt there's been some man who just
didn't do things right and
but but the solution to that is not to
empower necessarily
women beyond what allah is empowered
with you know because right now there's
a
there's so don't don't those bombs don't
represent
the actual illustration of islam if they
if they misrepresented they're not kind
they
don't like take the exception to the
okay exactly that's not the solution so
i think
right now there's there's a there's a
reaction movement on the other side
where women are being empowered if you
look at
as i said if you look at the female
sheikhas or the female
you know are given dawah they keep
talking about women empower yourself
take care of your body
go to the gym uh you know learn martial
i was just looking uh today someone said
you know
they're like mashallah doing kickboxing
all kinds of things
uh you know the women are mashallah you
know being told go out
be independent you keep hearing these
things and the shepherds are promoting
that look at their
uh their social media not that i'm just
looking to check i know people like are
you looking at them
it's it's people clients people before
things to me
i do check i check um look at their
speeches look at what they're talking
about
how many are saying hey sisters let's
sit at home and take care of our
children because they're being put into
schools for eight hours or in front of a
screen now for 10 hours or whatever
and they're being conditioned you know
and then you're like what's wrong with
my son why does he have this and that
so uh you know but where is the
sheikha's the sister
who are teaching the women to hey you
know let's um
take care of our household let's uh talk
about some ethics that teach our kids in
the house let's
uh you know respect our husbands let's
maybe you know
dress a bit better when the husband
comes outside from the fitnah that he
can actually look at something nice when
he comes in because that's his halal
all i'm saying is let's let's bring back
the sun of being balanced
if you want to talk about females rights
and empowerment let's talk about men's
rights in the parliament if you want to
talk about
feminine and listen let's talk about
masculinity right and then
and bottom line is the the man the man
is the imam of the house there's no if
ands and buts about it as much as people
are going to try to
go left and right and back and center
the man is the imam of the house
that is not just like i want to beat
myself in the chest haha we want it's
about responsibility accountability
it's about a lot of things that a man
has to carry on his shoulder
going back to the quran understanding
these things educating the community
we'll solve our problems keep inflating
the women empowering him and giving that
and deflating the man you know
smaller weaker yeah it's allowed to so
it's a lot to this you know but the
women are talking about kickboxing the
women are talking about raising their
fists in there
the women are demanding the rights the
women are pushing to go out
and work and wear pants and you know
do whatever and i don't dance in front
of people and play basketball in front
of people and whatnot
now that there's anything wrong with
that one i didn't say that
all i'm saying is look at the different
approaches empower
get strong this and that here not so
much because we have to be careful not
to be
ali yeah what do you want to do before
we conclude what do you want to say
that's why when i did the video i i
agreed with where you're coming from
your concerns you know
and sadly when you do these videos
people will send an attack towards you
and then send an attack towards mufti
and then i was getting some attacks as
well and is that look man
this we're not here we're trying to
reason we're not just because i did a
video it doesn't mean
i was just like and i don't know why
people do that
i heard that you're going to lose your
job and i was very disturbed by that i
was like why would you lose your job
you know this is pathetic you know and
the thing is just because i disagree
with the execution brother of gabriel
done
i knew where he was coming from i'm 100
with him it's just the execution and i
do that sometimes and we almost we all
make mistakes
but the thing is to someone to lose
their job for someone to get
hate yeah people sending you hate by
muslims look
we don't this attitude is a cultish
behavior yeah okay we love brother
murphy meng we love brother gabriel
brother eddie but if i make a mistake
you can't say it's ali who the hell is
what do you mean if i make a mistake you
tell brother he was wrong not
no we've seen good work yes okay you've
seen good works it's not good for us to
cross out cancel somebody
just because a mistake would deem them
to be to make
and this is society we live inside do
you make one mistake people forget about
you
that shouldn't be the case you know but
i just see as for example like
with mufti men even like for example the
danish interview i
i believe like he's already we can see
he's already under pressure
yeah yes some things he said i i can
understand because
he's under pressure and he wants to open
his door to taheed
around the world he doesn't want it to
be limited in different areas now that
can be argued
but whenever i think about this it
reminds me of the treaty of hodeidah and
when surah
was revealed yeah the sahaba on the on
their way to do um
yeah they got they're on their way
they're being stopped
they've been offered a a a agreement
that
if you heard today certain brothers um
well they would lose their mind can you
imagine that you're being told you're
going to hand off the hand over the
believing men
to the mushriks you're going to have
them over to the mushriks and then on
top of that
the ones you become who leave islam you
send them back
and if if muslims from here travel to
you you i mean
you're going to send them back and so
the agreement was like
and then allah sends a revelation and he
says we've given you a clear victory
the sahaba were like what claire victory
so in the moment
we think sometimes it's like this
doesn't make sense and
it's it's we are we're finished uh in
putting muhammad jab's word you know you
are finished you know you're finished
you're finished here we're literally
finished but the hikmah behind it and
even though kind of vocalizing his thing
against the prophet salallahu
and the companions not listening to the
prophet peace be upon him sometimes
there's
wisdom in certain things that are being
done and we have to even though from the
outside it's like
rough seriously like it might make you
cringe you might be like what the
hell we need to sometimes i believe look
at the bigger picture
uh with what brother gabriel is doing
brother muftimenk is doing prophet eddie
is doing
or what i'm doing on muhammad hijab
whatever it may be we shouldn't as
muslims have
hostility towards each other because
it's sad to see that the consequences of
that is that brother gabriel might lose
his job or get death threats and
get an attack and then i'm getting
attacked and then why should it be like
that let's understand brother gabriel is
coming from a place
of genuine concern and brother mufi meng
is coming from a genuine concern
we all are we're just trying to fight
the same battle in different means
and the reason why i wanted to do this
is to touch up on that muslims
don't attack each other there's no hymn
against me we're all that don't
turn against somebody just because you
disagree that's the reason why i wanted
to do this segment
to emphasize on that not emphasize on
the whole knitting thing et cetera
probably
made qualifications what females made
clarification i'm making further
clarifications
it's just brothers if we just disagree
or our sisters don't attack each other
don't be hostile towards each other well
i
it's not correct let's advise one
another we're trying to do something for
the dean to the best of our capabilities
let's try to understand each other if
there's clear battle clear-cut
button and you advise the person in
private and you continue and they do it
then the
the re the dean calls us if it's done in
public
you should now refute in public i i
understand that that was it well that's
all i wanted to
say okay so alhamdulillah i'm very happy
elated that uh we got both
you brothers together we cover covered a
lot
and uh inshallah we can we can do it
again
and let's just take a minute now and
explain what
this message we've heard the term islam
muslim
how would you uh we'll start with uh ali
how would you for somebody now they've
looked at some of the the
they read the quran you know they got a
lot of social pressure from family this
that and the other what do you like to
tell people to
kind of get them you know to where they
need to be to really
taking that that step that they need to
take to take the shahada to
or the the islam hater who's tuning in
he's a joe rogan fan
a jordan peterson fan and he's listening
to what the
com common sense things we're talking
about what would you like to tell them
their heart is open let's say their mind
is open what would you tell them
yeah to be honest like personally it's
like i said before it's like getting to
know someone you know if
if you wanted me to get to know you if
you're watching this
and imagine i was getting to know you
via a source
uh which was lying about you you will
not be happy with this you will not like
it
so the thing is it's what we're asking
you or what you would have been asking
me if i did that is to get to know you
personally
so to get to know you personally means
me spending time with you
you know me uh you opening up to me you
know
and getting to know each other and we
just want you to
the same thing that you would like for
yourself to apply it to the quran
and get to know the quran for itself you
know
and read it and learn it from the
muslims you know if you go
and learn it from an a um orientalist
you know
he's gonna give you he's gonna give you
an idea of what islam
is not you know he's gonna portray in a
certain way so what we're saying is come
to the right people inshallah and
there's many people you know we have
youtube now you have
access to learning about islam if you
want to and if you don't want to do that
then you really need to question
yourself and look in the mirror and say
okay do i really want to know the truth
about islam or i just want to stick to
my lies
because it makes me feel good and the
reality that islam is not what i think
it is
it's going to ruin my whole you know my
whole life so if that's the case then
the problem is within
so we're just asking you guys to read
the quran give it a chance inshallah
and ask god for guidance it's very
fundamental ask god for guidance
if this is the truth you believe in god
you do that and shall ask god
and read the quran because that's what i
did i'm a muslim now
what is islam gabriel what is islam we
keep hearing islam what is islam
well look i'll use a kind of like a
construction on the statement of kobe
bryant right
passed away uh he said you want first
place come
come with us you want uh something else
to go somewhere else right
um what i mean is by islam is number one
islam is the solution
to your world problems we need to
understand we present islam to the
people
if you don't tell them that islam has
something to offer that is
totally different than what they know
okay and you're so confident about it
it's not about me or about eddie or
this is about islam this is about the
truth
and i believe when we tell them we
ourselves have to feel it
man this is number one islam is number
one right
islam is the way of life that will solve
all your problems everyone is suffering
everyone has within the deep quiet
chambers of their hearts there's a war
inside every human being
okay everyone has a struggle and islam
is the medicine for that
read the quran do you know just come as
ali said
look listen to the people everything is
there it's available as the prophet
said islam will enter in every single
house
it will honor some and dishonor others
okay
you got to make sure you take your
stance which side do you want to be on
who do you want to you want to play
take first place then come with us you
want
to be to the bottom then you know do
your thing man but
we have to position ourselves we have to
even in our daw in our preaching
if you tell someone about islam that
islam is good
islam is good when you say also what i
have is good islam is
peace you say i have also peace or islam
is
is you know inclusive yeah i also have
inclusion everyone has got these terms
that we're using now these
concussions these terms that we've made
up um but you need to say what is islam
offering
difference that you don't have that the
rest of the world doesn't offer
i think this is what we need to
highlight and i believe people as
they've come
and they will come as they come
throughout the centuries
you know they'll enter the dean of allah
in in massachusetts
jazakallah thank you both my brothers it
was really nice to
have you both on the dean's show
jazakallah may god almighty allah reward
both you preserve you protect you
inshallah we do this again sometime
thank you salaam alaikum
subscribe right now